anybody watch the uh
what was the oscars the grammys last
time oh yeah
i feel like it's so outdated like i
think they they should just stop the
award shows
and just announce who the winners are
and then maybe do like a festival or
some [ __ ] because all i want to see like
performances but
you know having a host it's just it's
just so it seems so outdated man
i don't watch those in years i used to
love them
love them i never missed any of them i
used to work them for eve grammys
oscars golden globes i worked them for
years but they just seemed so outdated
man
oh didn't you see beyonce on the carpet
or something oh yeah did i ever daddy
saw her i saw uh i mean you name it did
you see margot robbie at one of those
marco robbie wolfe of wall street harley
quinn from suicide squad
harley quinn dude i was meeting her
waiting for an uber
you know i'm pretty confident around
women dude i was like
it was like it was like to catch a
smuggler and i had cocaine in my bag
so where are you going like nowhere no
no what was that movie she did with will
smith
no that's usually that's charlie's thing
i know you're talking no she didn't
movie will smith
oh wait it was like were they like on
people out of the con artist
yeah dude she was smoke dude you know
who smoked
show in person it's paris hilton and i
don't like skinny girls really you saw
that documentary
she was reading i was like oh my she was
so pretty you know
i actually haven't seen a picture of a
video of paris hilton in years i haven't
either and then
i saw like sort of get out of her uber
because i was waiting after i think it
was going globe she was there
she gets out and she's walking up my god
god who is that
yeah and she got close i'm like oh [ __ ]
that's pierce hilton she was so pretty
man she's a dj now wow she's a dj
yeah would she have a podcast is this a
podcast yeah she recently started a
podcast who doesn't have one
i know right yeah uh her documentary is
kind of great because she's always on
her phone
and she was in a relationship with this
guy and all she dj's as well
and uh he just didn't he was like a
london guy like an [ __ ]
and before her biggest performances like
a festival of my life they got into it
and they broke up with her
and she's like man you always do this
and she's like this is why i'm always on
my phone
because you don't get me people don't
get like how she
makes money it's on her phone yeah and
she's like breaks down so
she's like but now she's married now so
good for her yeah she's definitely knows
what she's doing
you know she's smart she has so many
videos she's got she's the one who put
uh
nicole richie on she's the one who could
kardashian
kim kardashian designer assistant yeah
and she would bring kim with her to red
carpet and that's when
all the black dude's like who the [ __ ]
is that
and then ray j was like what's up
yeah bro you want to talk about closet
she doesn't wear the same thing
uh twice right her clothes
the jeweler and stuff they give to her
and then they take back they said
a lot a lot of people julie if it's like
real like millions of dollars they don't
buy it they just give it to him
like anything you see people at the ward
shows they don't own that oh they're
just weird
no like gucci or who dior whatever kind
of like promotion
yeah they'll be like okay we're this
people ask you say you were in dior
and then they come two days later and
take your [ __ ] that's what happened with
me they gave me
the dopest outfits and two day literally
huh can i pay you for that promo at
least
no you just literally shook you up with
like oh there's two thousand dollars
worth of dope [ __ ] and the stylist and
then they take it back i'll take it i'll
be like i'm wearing this sweater no you
can though because if it's like custom
fitted to your body they'll be like you
can keep that because we can't
fit down anybody else but if it's like
shoes or yeah
jewelry i'm assuming you would have to
get a lot of custom [ __ ] yeah
yeah he's just on my most more like a
session
but to your point though i've uh because
i have to get so much custom stuff you
would like you can just keep it all my
outfits from
the oscars golden globes academy awards
the grammys damn i have like
dope ass outfits that i'll never wear
but yeah where you can wear it just like
dope ass suits oh so sick yeah we're
gonna wear it like crushed velvet like
dope [ __ ] really
yeah velvet dude we had a purple suit
right purple suit
that's that broke on you know when they
do bro
mm-hmm you know they do the slow cam
that broke you have that video
it's on instagram uh i think i posted i
was like shout out to the oscars
remember when i worked oscars and
ripped my suit yeah you they you on me
they have like the i forget what it's
called
it's like the fashion it is that slow
they're like hey yeah yeah they like
rush over me like hey they want you to
do the fashion cam like really
like yeah and i had the suit and i went
to go like this with it
like throw it open like look all dope
yeah and it [ __ ] ripped right down
the middle in the back
oh you can see my face i'm like oh how
much is that suit worth
i don't know is it still ripped to this
day
like somewhere in your closet that's it
right there
i love her uh what's that uh the big
girl yeah
y'all no no no no no no she's she look
at that
outfit done [ __ ] she does a lot of the
big
i was on the uh with her the black girl
yeah i was on that on that dating no
filter
with her [ __ ] what's her name she hosts
all the loving hip-hop uh reunions
i'm having the time yeah she does oh
look at this right here that's your suit
uh one of them yeah
damn would you work the oscars but you
basically see your point the grammys is
dead
uh but even the views are like way down
like way way down what's the uh after
this chance you see the views uh for the
moment because i remember the only thing
that reminded me about the grammys was
bill burr
what uh he had like a little uh i guess
he was tweeting about it or something
like that i said oh i forgot the grammys
was on last night
recording record low but uh but so
the grammys the oscars the golden glo
all of them
i mean but also like brian mc's point
all the time like can you name a move
like when you look at the oscars like
i get they're trying to be woke how
about just the best actress the best
actor
the best movies win yeah [ __ ] your
narrative on woke and
chinese black white i don't give a [ __ ]
if all black people win just make the
best
movie best actors win don't do it
because you think that's what society
wants
yeah just have the best people win and
then people would [ __ ] pay attention
mm-hmm yeah earlier awards on measly 7.9
million viewers
um record low
last year was 18. dude cut in half i
heard it was kind of weird too because
the only people who could go were
people who were nominated for the oscars
like socially distanced
people are giving harry uh styles a lot
of [ __ ] because
he went up during dosha cat's
performance and he was like talking to a
bunch of people he was like making his
rounds
oh no oh no what are we gonna do
oh where do you think he tested negative
you think they would let you know
they thought it was disrespectful that
he was doing it during her performance
oh not necessarily because of kovitz
okay it's boring as [ __ ] man yeah it
spices the [ __ ] up well hold on don't
look at
it
[Applause]
is
she talks about how she likes getting uh
stepped on
sexually oh i'm into that what the [ __ ]
is that although i get a size 13 girl
i'm like you asked for a girl
what's the [ __ ] safe word dog
john enchilada
tessie you're my bestie is that my
bestie and a tassie
damn what the [ __ ] he said imagine
brenda's big ass is on your
[ __ ] if that if that's what you're
into cats [ __ ] me they're sure
too that's weird where do you read that
oh no i saw an interview
she was doing because they were talking
about uh like some weird like
secret king she was into she said that
she likes having her face stepped on
like with a shoe on i just barefoot i
would imagine barefoot
barefoot for sure barefoot she's so used
to dating like really scrawny awkward
white dudes
so like i don't know
i think her her face can handle like a
scrawny white
yeah it's not necessarily something
that's what changes kelly's stepping on
her face she's good
yeah well i think ass jump on there i
know she did i don't know about back she
might be talking about white guys you
know black guys we keep our socks on
yeah you do
is she a little freak
well she seems like a freak
yeah those award no one knows your time
out so i'm gonna carry on right i do but
the listeners can't so no one's gonna
get it
um yeah those awards are just strange
man
it's just beyonce one she's the most
winningest uh
female of all time i think now i think
any uh person
for the singing category as well but for
female i believe she's like the most
awarded
what about michael jackson michael
jackson no i think beyonce
took it they love her at the grammys
though but i mean like you said the best
let the best one win yeah and she put
out fire albums
i don't know yeah it's just i mean
george [ __ ]
right now like award shows do we care
about them like the weekend is
boycotting the grammys
you don't care about you seeing them
performing i don't give a [ __ ] you you
don't care about them not the grammys i
don't even [ __ ]
i liked him at the super bowl so if he
never performs on tv again i'll just
watch on youtube
i don't give a [ __ ] so the great other
grammys you don't care about who's
performing don't care
you just want to see who want to win no
i don't know because what is it what
does it mean to you
if they win what's up never
all those award shows i've never given
up but also if you let the public vote
on what was the best movie like avengers
would win every year
yeah yeah and then they're wrong with
that that's what i'm saying
so it's like it's this weird group who
decides
what movie's the best the committee yeah
it's this weird [ __ ] committee
actually source awards 95. should you
watch that what about hip-hop wars
what i'm saying that one was funny to me
though oh but i get what you're saying
like let the people vote
okay and it's weird because like taylor
swift when she's like this this because
the fans like fans had
nothing to do with this yeah who the
[ __ ] they have no vote he just said he's
a committee like
it's like 12 people the the the
committee you know everyone
for a while was like oh well i guess
oscars they're in trouble because it's
all white committee
so that's why you see you know not that
the movies are bad but
a lot of the candidates are
asian-american or african-american
because they're like because like two
years ago it was like all white people
and then they're like oh let's look at
the committee and they're all white
guys that's a problem and the grammys
they had like one black guy because the
week the
the head the guy who runs the thing is
black black that's what they were saying
in the weekend was like man it's all
it got to be racial that was like nah
it's a black guy up there but again
like it is weird but he also
acknowledged he's like we don't get it
right all the time
well that's why you [ __ ] idiot
shouldn't have this power though yeah
this should be half fan vote half of you
guys i guess
like you're giving these idiots too much
power yeah especially who the [ __ ]
that guy if you know what he's doing
he'd be singing
why is he critiquing everyone's yeah do
you even listen to this [ __ ] what's
it say
it's like the same people like you dead
spin or whoever write articles on
uh a stand-up comic special if they knew
anything about comedy
they would be doing it true so you're
gonna critique dave chappelle
or kevin hart what the [ __ ] yeah who are
you
and also subjective
like this person might hate dave
chappelle's comedy
but the majority of people [ __ ] love
him and then you dictate you yeah
yeah that's that is music too like
dozier cat compared to beyonce you're
talking about apples and oranges
so how are you going to decide for
racing with this weird committee
yeah for ratings i think if you want
people to like pay attention
get people involved like you don't have
people like let's be a fan
like mtv music awards is all fan driven
i would imagine those are bigger than
this
oh yeah i used to watch those mtv music
videos yeah those were actually pretty
[ __ ] that's all fan driven now
now when here's the problem when you do
that bts
asians ride for theirs so bts won
every award possible but again oh they
did their ratings their ratings were up
there though yeah i know but the problem
is it's like is
is be that's where it gets tricky like
is bts the best i think they're great i
love you yeah but not the best
but they want it if you're in every
category nationally yes
everyone in every category maybe but but
here's the promise like there's so many
asians
right well that's more asians than
americans true
so if you're going to open up the
international voting which they do bts
can win every single award
what's like yao mean he was always the
number one all-star vote getter because
they opened up voting to china
does that mean he's the best player was
it bees was he the best
kobe duck though bad yeah shaq used to
expose them
but i get what you say it's just weird
yeah it is i love
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front run a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son